bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 4 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale a tout de suite les
titres de cette édition
christophe naudin le français impliqué
dans l'exfiltration à la fin du mois
d'octobre des pilotes de la sphère air
cocaïne a été extradé d'egypte vers la
république dominicaine aujourd'hui son
frère et illinois il réagira dans ce
journal
le maire l'avait annoncé l'année
dernière le marché des clayes-sous-bois
va être reconstruit en début 2010 est un
parking et un immeuble seront réalisés à
la place du marché actuel une décision
qui ne fait pas l'unanimité auprès d'ecc
les siens et enfin troisième épisode de
notre série consacrée aux yvelinois
présent au salon de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui reportage sur le monument
café le restaurant à versailles était en
démonstration au salon porte de
versailles cette semaine et je vous le
disais en titre l'egypte à extra
d'aujourd'hui christophe naudin vers
saint domingue
le français était recherché pour son
implication dans l'évasion de deux
pilotes français condamné dans la sphère
air cocaïne
le criminologue et spécialistes de la
sûreté aérienne avait arrêté le 4
février au caire en raison d'un mandat
d'arrêt émis par la république
dominicaine qui l'accusent comme il l'a
reconnu lui-même d'avoir participé à
l'évasion des deux pilotes français
pascal forêt et bruno d'eau
condamné à 20 ans de prison pour trafic
de drogue dans la sphère elle cocaïne
nous sommes ce soir en direct avec son
frère éric naudin qui est yvelinois
bonsoir et naudin vous avez appris
l'extradition
bonsoir vous avez après l'extradition de
votre aujourd'hui est ce que vous
attendez tout d'abord à une telle
décision
elop que jamais coup d'un mandat d'arrêt
pour l'évasion le monde
et complètement fallacieux puisqu'il
était sous le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt
n'est me bats plus de binicais trafic
d'êtres humains et traite de migrants
qui sont des motifs inhabituellement in
à voir avec tafer ce qui prouve bien le
façon dont ils risquent d'être jugé par
la suite
vous avez des contacts aujourd'hui avec
le gouvernement voulant pas ça de
française à saint domingue est ce que
vous savez comment ce comment se trouve
votre sphère où il en est et ce qui se
passe exactement
alors actuellement il est en transit qui
les en avion dont il n'est pas encore
arrivé sur le territoire dominicain
je suis entré en contact avec le député
des français de l'étranger sur la zone
caraïbes repli dominicaine et nous
cherchons actuellement à s'assurer deux
des meilleures conditions de détention
pour mon frère et de la meilleure
défense possible
voilà ma belle-soeur la femme de mon
frère est pas en relation étroite en ce
moment avec le milf eid affaires
étrangères pour essayer aussi de voir ce
qu'il est possible de faire alors vous
deviez venir sur notre plateau ce soir
bien sûr nous comprenons que forcément
voilà vous ayez une est à cette affaire
plus importante à gien quelles vont être
les démarches que vous allez engager à
partir d'aujourd'hui pour essayer
d'aider votre frère ça va être des
contacts avec le consul avait des
contacts avec les différends politiques
impliqués donc sénateurs et députés sur
les zones république dominicaine sur les
hommes régime parce qu'il ya encore des
choses qui sont flous sur ce côté là
avec les sénateurs et députés de la
circonscription où habitait mon frère
des relations avec lui salve affaires
étrangères le quai d'orsay pour montrer
aussi que beaucoup de choses dans cette
affaire sont floues voire fausses que si
jamais il était jugé regarde une justice
partiale
il serait probablement pas en train de
risque et 15 à 20 ans de prison pour ce
qu'il a fait ici qui l'a récupéré deux
français sur les eaux internationales et
autres nationale aider à ramener en
france c'est compliqué de d'estimer un
atelier gagnent là dedans même si elle
comprend le
de la ferme vous craignez que votre
frère pays pour justement les pilotes
qui l'a aidée à sortir
oui complètement le quai d'orsay selon
voit-il suffisamment joué à son rôle
pour protéger peut-être pour délimiter à
votre frère dans cette affaire
aujourd'hui on a réussi à mobiliser
l'état français à partir de l'année
dernier suite à la non de l'extradition
avant on avait des contacts extrêmement
timide alors je suis bien que nous les
diplomates ne me dise pas tout même s'il
était dans l'action ne dirait pas mais
en tout cas le sentiment qu'on a de
l'extérieur c'est très peu de choses
sont faites pas assez et il a maintenant
on est vraiment dans l' angoisse surtout
que mon frère a des preuves de ce conte
est important il est suivi il a été
hospitalisé pendant sont à présent en
egypte et on ne sait pas comment se fera
la suite de sa détention république
dominicaine vous adapter au président à
françois hollande aujourd'hui on l'a
déjà fait je ne fais pas fille
aujourd'hui ça aura du sens bien
évidemment que si jamais il se mobilise
pleinement il peut faire beaucoup mais
je suis persuadé que ne s'est pas dans
son désir se mobiliser par contre
certains politiques plus proche de
république dominicaine avec de
meilleures relations plus sur le terrain
auront sûrement une meilleure écoute
mais aujourd'hui je n'ai jamais dit il à
toutes les volontés que ce soit françois
hollande manuel valls monsieur ayrault
les différends politiques tous ceux qui
sont en capacité de faire quelque chose
et même les particuliers les entreprises
tous ceux qui auraient des relations
qu'ils sont capables de faire entendre
raison à la république dominicaine voilà
j'en mobile à toutes les forces
possibles votre votre communauté mon
comité de soutien justement c'est un peu
votre frère va agir vous allez à faire
des événements organisés des initiatives
très prochainement dans les prochains
jours justement pour pour votre frère
pour l'instant je vais pas répondre à la
question pour la simple raison que
on veut agir le plus sereinement le plus
intelligemment possible et on voudrait
pas en menant des actions de force se
mettre à dos les politiques qui
pourraient nous aider donc je pense pas
honnêtement que ce soit à l'ordre du
jour par contre de continuer à
communiquer on n'a plus une page
facebook et un compte twitter site
internet de communiquer sur sa situation
et puis de recueillir les soutiens
possibles des gens qui ont des idées
parfois est donc incertain nous apporter
des idées et dit ça c'est important
voilà ce qu'on nous apporte des conseils
nous apporte des choses comme ça ça
c'est important mais aujourd'hui faire
des actions de mobilisation c'est
compliqué on avait une pétition en ligne
par exemple cette pétition commence à
recueillir plusieurs centaines de
signatures
on pense que ça peut avoir du sens si on
amène à nos politiques une pétition qui
est très fournie qui montre quel intérêt
les français ont pour christophe naudin
qui est quelqu'un qui était déjà
médiatique avant cette histoire et dans
la très bonne avec un très bon enfant il
a fait beaucoup pour la france il a fait
beaucoup pour la sûreté de notre pays
il a été distingué par lui femmes
intérieur est officier dans les écoles
de police et de gendarmerie
on est papa d'un voyou voilà ça je crois
que l'état français aujourd'hui ne tient
pas compte
merci beaucoup eric naudin d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions et
de vous être exprimé en duplex merci au
revoir merci à vous l affaire médiator
revient dans l'actualité le médicament
développé par les laboratoires servier
comme est commercialisé depuis 1976 est
interdit en 2009
amener les dirigeants du groupe devant
les tribunaux pour tromperie aggravée le
cas d'une victime une femme de 67 ans
était plaidé pour la seconde fois ce
matin à versailles en cour d'appel cette
femme qui a consommé du médiator de 2006
à 2009 demande au tribunal une nouvelle
expertise médicale destinée à mieux
cerner son préjudice et 50000 euros de
provision à servier a servi hier et très
a réitéré pardon sa pop sa position
jeudi selon ses avocats les
connaissances sur le défaut du médiator
était très progressive le
ce cas n'a été avéré qu'en 2009 selon
toujours les avocats version contestée
évidemment par la défense de la malade
la cour rendra sa décision le 14 avril
autre information les yvelines en
troisième position des dix départements
les plus flashé en 2015 le département
enregistre 387 1394 infractions relevées
juste derrière le département de
l'essonne et paris l'activité des trois
radars les plus actifs dans le
département celui de bailly sur
l'autoroute a12 celui de versailles sur
la des 185 et le troisième à guerville
sur l'a13 en direction de paris
enregistre en moyenne trente mille flash
par an soit 82 par jour la préfecture
des yvelines a dévoilé l'activité des 80
un radar automatique du département il
ya quelques semaines ces radars ont été
installés à des endroits précis où des
accidents ont été relevés au terme de
cinq ans d'observation selon le service
de l'éducation et la sécurité routière
de la préfecture et des yvelines et nous
allons parler à présent agriculture nous
continuons notre série sur les yvelinois
du salon de l'agriculture avec le
troisième épisode épisode consacré cette
fois ci au restaurant le monument café
ce restaurant versailles est ouvert
depuis 2012 était présent à la
manifestation pour faire connaître son
concept mettre en avant le patrimoine
culinaire et historique français nous
sommes allés les suivre lundi dernier au
salon de l'agriculture lors de leur
démonstration regardez donc ça c'est la
bizarrerie qu'on fait toutes les
semaines
donc cette semaine c'est des tripes à la
mode de caen
à peine âgé de 24 ans est déjà chef
cuisinier à versailles depuis un an et
demi axel s'activent faire découvrir le
patrimoine culinaire français au
monument café en revisitant des plats
traditionnels
cette année c'est la première fois qu'il
propose une démonstration au salon de
l'agriculture
on va au salon les vecteurs pour
présenter notre cuisine à base de
produits ile de france pendant qu'on va
réaliser des préparations préliminaire
et ensuite on sera plus sûr du dressage
et de la finition sur le lieu du salon
donc les enjeux pour pour un
restaurateur comme moi d'être au salon
de la culture celle où mon de mettre en
avant
notre savoir-faire notre restaurant il
ya pas de stress particulier pour nous
c'est plus du partage donc et les
échanges avec les visiteurs donc c'est
vraiment un moment de détente ça nous
sort de notre quotidien au restaurant
nous retrouvons les deux acolytes porte
de versailles à paris pour cette
démonstration ils ont élaboré leur
recette ou menus champignons crème de
bris oignons et même une pointe de
citron
on travaillait produits qui sont dans le
garde manger on les présente aux gens en
fait une petite présentation et puis on
va dresser dans des verrines un travail
sur une bonne partie de ce lundi après
midi environ 300 verrines ont été
dressés
les visiteurs font la queue pour y
goûter tout en puissance avec le brie de
melun aux herbes au départ réhaussée par
la chaleur et on va dire adoucie par la
compotée de de champignons et d'oignons
produits locaux et savoir faire
authentique deux ingrédients qui ont su
séduire la clientèle
après quelques années d'existence
l'établissement ouvert deux autres
antennes à angers et chambord pari
réussi et trois représentants yvelinois
ont été primés au salon de l'agriculture
alors il ya trois produits le petit cru
un fromage fabriqué par la ferme de la
tramblais à la boissière école la vole
céleste ombre et une bière de la
brasserie de la vallée de chevreuse
abonnés les le chaudron un pâté de
campagne au sel de guérande des
salaisons des boucles de la seine à
boissy sans avoir
ils ont été récompensés au concours
général agricole qui s'est déroulée dans
le cadre du salon de l'agriculture
les trois yvelinois font partie des
producteurs d'île de france à avoir été
médaillés par un jury composé de
professionnels mais aussi d'amateurs
ce concours créé en 1870 par le
ministère de l'agriculture récompense
les meilleurs produits du terroir alors
la bière la volt est a reçu la médaille
d'argent cette bière est produite avec
de l'orge provenant de la vallée de
chevreuse le petit cru vendus sous la
marque commerciale de ferme de jouvence
s'est vu attribuer avec le chaudron la
médaille de bronze et partons à présent
aux clayes-sous-bois les
clayes-sous-bois les travaux du nouveau
marché devrait démarrer début 2010 est
un parking et un neuf seront réalisés à
la place du marché actuel une décision
qui ne fait pas l'unanimité auprès d'ecc
les siens détails avec mélanie côté la
mairie lajus très vétuste là
halle couverte du marché des
clayes-sous-bois va être démoli avant la
destruction une nouvelle halle sera
construite juste en face sur un terrain
précédemment acquis par la commune
déplacer parce que ça permet un marché
existant de continuer à fonctionner
pendant les travaux et d'éviter une
rupture d'activité qui pénaliserait et
les les commerçants et leurs impôts même
leur emploi d'interpeler rendre de la
mettre dans une situation précaire mais
qui pénalisera également les
consommateurs qui serait donc privé de
marché pendant un certain temps le
marché actuel accueille une centaine de
commerçants l'association des
commerçants du marché souligne les
avantages mais non sans inquiétude
de toute façon ce qui bloque
de notre côté il nous inquiète surtout
c'est les deux ans et demi trois ans que
vont durer les travaux parce que le
nouveau marché citons amandine est dès
maintenant ça va être pendant pendant
trois ans de la poussière des camions
pour à la place du marché actuel un
immeuble d'habitation collectifs et
départ qui nous verront le jour
l'opposition municipale de son côté
reproche le manque de concertation
auprès d'ecc les siens des élus
d'opposition et des commerçants la
question du stationnement des riverains
leur semble aussi problématique
nous sommes aussi évidemment inquiet sur
la
venir dès ce qu'on appelle les ambulants
et les volants et ce qui rend
aujourd'hui attractif le marché c'est
évidemment leur présence lorsque des
déplacements et des réhabilitations ont
été faites sur les marchés de saint cyr
ou de plaisir par exemple on a vu aussi
une baisse de fréquentation parce que
précisément les ambulants qui rendait
attractif ce marché ont disparu elle la
mairie a lancé un appel d'offres les
travaux de la future halle devrait
démarrer début 2010 est pour une
ouverture en 2018 et chaque année elles
sont de plus en plus nombreuses à voir
le jour en france les bières artisanales
ont aujourd'hui le vent en poupe
une manière de faire découvrir de
nouvelles saveurs en proposant un
produit fabriqué localement à proximité
des consommateurs à bois d'arcy trois
amis d'enfance qui partagent la même
passion pour le houblon ont décidé de
créer leur propre marque de bière c'est
william est elle qui vous en parle a
passé le début le début
après le choix des ingrédients
le début du brassage d'accord on appelle
l'empaquetage c'est
le malt le voilà plusieurs variétés sont
ainsi mélangés dans ses cuves qui
fermente euros jusqu'à ébullition pour
obtenir du mou donc là ça aux blancs
américains qu'on appelle le millénium
qui augmenterait à mes raisons et qui
est très avant qu'un casse aromatiques
aussi donc là on va on va au blosne et
notre moore avec souvent du coup là on a
un mousse et un jus sucré
on a obtenu en brassant de la bière donc
là on est sur un jeu qui est vraiment
noir à mont noir sont en train de
brasser un stade c'est une bière
la stout c'est une des nouvelles pierres
locales de bois d'arcy depuis dix ans et
trois amis brasse pour le plaisir mais
en décembre dernier ils ont décidé de
créer leur propre marque
au départ on est parti sur trois bières
savoir donc une american people in india
pédaler un start donc ces deux bières
blondes plus ou moins amère à
aromatique avec des houblons très
aromatique et installe donc une bière
noire type irlandaise on risque de
brasser cette année aux alentours de 400
hectolitres de bière c'est à dire 40
mille litres
une affaire qui débute plutôt bien pour
l'instant ces brasseurs ali vente petits
commerces restaurateurs et cavistes
locaux b projet d'augmenter leur
production pour l'instant on distribue
en ile-de-france et puis quand on sera
amené à distribuer un petit peu plus
loin on aura juste à racheter des cuves
de fermentation pour augmenter notre
capacité de production
nous on fait des produits atypiques qui
ont du goût tout nos biens ne plaisent
pas à tout le monde mais c'est justement
ça le jeu dans leur petit local de la
zone industrielle de la croix bonnet
quentin kevin et sébastien sont fiers de
produire la première bière locale de
bois d'arcy avec une prévision de
production d'au moins 90 mille
bouteilles pour la première année
l'alcool a consommé à modération bien
sûr vous savez on ouvre à présent une
page sports notre journaliste sportif et
mickaël ennemi d'euros nous a rejoints
sur le plateau bonsoir à michael sommer
suis ravi de vous retrouver aimez-vous
le billard oui j'adore j'ai fait des
compétitions d'ailleurs dans ma jeunesse
1 et bien vous allez travail il faudrait
n'est pas coutume nous allons parler à
billard dans cette chronique le tournoi
national black ball est programmée à
partir de ce vendredi jusqu'à ce
dimanche au centre sportif les pyramides
de voisins-le-bretonneux pour nous
parler de cette compétition nous
recevons alain rousset président du
billard club vit sinois organisateur de
l'épreuve
bonsoir bonjour alors pourquoi avoir
décidé d'organiser cette compétition à
une question
c'est l'histoire du club de voisins on
va on est dans un 23e année de création
on s'est promis tous les quatre ans 52
organiser une compétition importante
ça serait tic pour valoriser notre ville
aussi et donc on renvoie l'ascenseur en
quelque sorte à la municipalité
puisqu'elle nous a toujours soutenus
et donc cette année on va organiser un
tournoi très important on va dire en
termes exacts à organiser oui ça sera la
première fois qu'on accueille autant de
joueurs il y en a tant de joueurs
justement je crois qu'on est à 380 on
avait 10 400 et voilà on est dans la
fourchette haute on est donc 400 joueurs
à peu près de 380 je crois aux dernières
nouvelles donc cette compétition va se
dérouler sur deux jours et demi elle va
commencer demain soir et samedi toute la
journée tard et le dimanche avec remise
des prix pour les catégories
individuelles le dimanche par cas vers
16h 16h30 et ça va se continuer un petit
peu avec la fin des tournois par équipes
et puis après on déménage tout et on
rend à la ville de voisins le gymnase on
part fait état pour le lundi matin pour
les écoliers et pouvez vous nous
présenter le black ball pour les non
initiés
alors le black ball en fait c'est plus
connus où s'étaient connus sous
l'appellation de poule
donc c'est des petits billard à poches
avec six trous et avec des billes de
couleurs rouge et jaune et donc le jeu
consiste
c'est une confrontation entre deux
joueurs après ce qu'on appelle la casse
dispersés débit sur le billard le joueur
un moment donné entre une couleur donnée
et il doit le premier vide et sa couleur
et en terminer par ce qu'on appelle la 8
voire blanche donc le 8 et ça sera le
gain de la manche et la victoire et ce
premier qui arrive à un certain nombre
de manches gagnantes donc vous disiez
380 joueurs est ce que le niveau soit
relevé il y aura des très bons joueurs
je suis là on aura les meilleurs joueurs
français
c'est clair puisque on a tous les
masters on a les 32 meilleurs joueurs
français qui seront présents on peut pas
faire mieux puisque on va trouver des
joueurs de niveau européen évidemment
puisqu'ils ont fait les championnats de
france ils sont qualifiés pour l'europe
pour des championnats du monde et on a
quelques joueurs qui ont atteint des
niveaux très élevés des actions en
europe et c'est donc on a vraiment le
top
dans les joueurs français à travers ce
circuit donc il ya des joueurs de black
ball master en compétition mixte des
vétérans 2 il ya 40 ans oui les juniors
oui il a vraiment pour tous les goûts en
fait au final pour ça qu'à otthoffer en
fait ça se gère plusieurs catégories
c'est une épreuve en fait c'est une
épreuve
comment qui s'organise sur plusieurs
fois en france donc sur dans plusieurs
villes je n'ai pas cité le nom des
bidonvilles calais albi enfin et c'est
donc va y avoir huit 8 rencontres au
niveau national de ses 400 joueurs à peu
près et qui vont se confronter et les
meilleurs seront qualifiés pour une
grande finale de france avec beaucoup
moins de joueurs évidemment puisque il y
aura une élimination au fur et à mesure
des tournois mais c'est un command ap
sarah circuit c'est un circuit organisé
par la fédération française de billard
et tout est prévu en début d'année
structurer les billards arrive par un
semi-remorque et s'est installé mais
tout ça en oeuvre et puis faire jouer
toutes ces catégories et donc il y aura
six catégories de joueurs féminines
juniors
ces masters nationale 1 donc les masters
cd 32 meilleurs joueurs de france
merci les pas sur ce plateau bon courage
pour l'organisation je suppose que voilà
il va falloir encore beaucoup de travail
pour jusqu'à demain soir
oui merci merci à vous merci cette page
de bien nous allons parler à présent
handball effet ni les féminines de
montigny le bretonneux joueront ce
week-end ou tel un match sous haute
pression montigny qui porte actuellement
à l'avant-dernière place du classement
de national une reçoit octeville sur mer
6e ce samedi à 20h30 au complexe sportif
pierre de coubertin
la rencontre est déterminante dans la
lutte pour le maintien une victoire
pourrait permettre aux signé montaigne
de sortir de la zone rouge en cas de
défaite montini pourrait commencer à
préparer la saison prochaine
je vous rappelle florane que l'ess mba a
changé d'entraîneur il ya trois semaines
bruno filipe a remplacé philippe
l'étrange depuis ce changement montigny
est invaincu espérons qu'elle le reste
jusqu'à la fin de la saison on termine à
cette chronique en roue libre avec une
course mythique
pour la septième année consécutive la
course cycliste paris nice organisé du 6
au 13 mars s'élancera depuis les
yvelines la ville de conflans sainte
honorine a été choisi pour le prologue
de cette soixante quatorzième édition
avec au programme 6 km avec le fameux
senti des laveuses une cote de 200 m une
deuxième vie libinois sera également à
l'honneur sur ce paris-nice 2016 condé
sur vègre 1159 habitants a été
sectionnée pour accueillir le départ de
la première étape de la compétition
une première pour ce village situé près
de rambouillet une centaine de coureurs
est intervenu sur paris nice parmi les
têtes d'affiché on retrouvera les stars
françaises romain bardet tony gallopin
l'italien fabio aru et l'espagnol
alberto contador vainqueur du tour de
france et vainqueur de l'épreuve
l'épreuve en 2007 et 2010 alors que deux
stars un beau plateau une nouvelle fois
pour ce paris nice à michael on vous
retrouve dans quelques instants il me
semble pour votre talk show si on
parlait sport quel sera le programme ou
trois ans de plus alors oui florennes
avec nos chroniqueurs nous parlerons des
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste qui se dérouleront au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mais également
de basket avec la série d'invincibilité
du chesnay versailles 78 dans le
championnat de nationale 3 films et bien
on a hâte de découvrir ça merci beaucoup
à michael nous allons parler maintenant
théâtre et si votre enfant était le
futur leonardo dicaprio l'atelier du
prisme elle encourt lui permettra
peut-être de révéler son talent et
pourquoi pas d'avoir un oscar peut-être
un peu plus rapidement les petits héros
comtois ont été mis à l'honneur cette
semaine pendant les vacances lors d'un
stage un atelier au prisme leur a été
dédié il s'inscrit dans le cadre des
vacances créatives proposé pour la
première fois par l'établissement
un reportage signé michael vidéo et
camille lambert se saluer tout en
équilibrant l'espace scénique l'un des
premiers enseignements que l'on apprend
au théâtre depuis lundi 29 avril sont
huit à bénéficier les conseils d'une
professionnelle
une première pour le prisme des locaux
ce stage s'inscrit dans le cadre de
notre programmation vacances créatives
qui
viennent de se mettre en place cette
saison l'idée c'était de pouvoir
proposer à des enfants de passer leurs
vacances dans un théâtre avec une
activité artistique travail sur le corps
relation à l'autre
articulation autant d'exercices abordé
toute la journée sous la direction
d'evelyne bages et comédienne depuis 40
ans le plus important pour elle c'est de
donner la parole à ces jeunes élèves
on apprend des choses on s'amuse
le professeur est super sympa enfin on
fait plein de trucs que moi j'avais pas
fait de stage avant et pas du tout
théâtre et du coup bah j'ai appris plein
de choses on travaille sur des exercices
de mise en scène et aussi sur notre voie
nos mouvements pleins de l'exercice qui
font un peu des enfants qui font
référence un peu au théâtre des émotions
travail et la colère le dégoût la
tristesse avec l'aide de leurs
professeurs ils ont créé plusieurs
saynètes en laissant libre cours à leur
imagination
les petits comédiens ont encore jusqu'à
vendredi pour parfaire leur prestation
avant de se représenter sur scène devant
leurs parents le prisme prévoit déjà une
deuxième édition de ses vacances
créatives pour le mois d'avril
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivis rester avec nous
dans quelques instants vous retrouvez
votre talk show si on parlait sport avec
michael et demi d'euros demain vous avez
rendez vous avec le wilfried errishi
pour l'essentiel de l'actualité ce vrai
benoît hamon notre invité reviendra sur
sa proposition de loi pour reconnaître
le burn out comme maladie
professionnelle ainsi que sur son
opposition au projet de loi sur le
travail de myriam el khomri quant à moi
je vous retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle
édition du journal je vous souhaite donc
une belle soirée et un excellent week
end